yes welcome Video playing
[Music]
in
okay
ne
play quick
B5 playable maybe
SC
long
surprising
yes not
C
King
B H3 yes
maybe yes i was thinking about
that
die5 yes please unlucky Spot
here
Problem inend Bishop B7 Bishop
B7
C6
[Music]
takes
Queen
surprising
okay under
D
mi
completcion
okay never abut never
cannot really
take can I can actually Queen takes K C7
still still playable
playable Option Queen
B7 Queen B7
en
ja okay
let
F4
c7ing
Bri
okayening
yes what my King
doing was bad
decision
tja
trying to  get Queen B4
H4 maybe take
F6 nothing
do
moment4
strong
Check Check Check Check Check
Check yes Bad
game
refute
play
Check
yes first game
[Music]
session
yes
don't like Position h
[Music]
allen in
book maybe not so
[Music]
cle
long
okay
something like may
play yes tricky maybe overestim
bit can C not the end of the
world can
play very weakening
King
May
Comp
yes